- John Wick, you voted for it.
Lots of injuries. Lots of gore.
I'm gonna break it down.
B-whoa!
(ominous strings swooping)
Be careful, John!
(pipe clanging)
All right, first concussion.
I feel like he's gonna
get concussed a lot here.
If you're getting hit with a solid object
on the back of your skull, ow!
That's gonna cause a very serious injury.
Not only is it gonna
split your skull open,
you're gonna start bleeding a lot,
but also you're gonna
get your brain rattled.
That's a concussion.
Ooh.
Abdomen kick right into
the solar plexus, ah!
Knocks the wind right outta you.
Ooh, broken arm looks
like right in the humerus.
At least a bone bruise, at least.
Oh, kick in the face.
Broken nose.
After getting hit in the head
with a baseball bat, he's out.
He's out cold.
(man speaking foreign language)
So this is, the funny
part about this movie is
they're supposed to be speaking Russian.
It's not Russian folks!
I don't know what he's saying.
See the fact that his
nose stopped bleeding here
is also not real.
Like what made his nose stop bleeding?
It would actually become a problem,
'cause he's laying on his back.
It's gonna go right into his oral cavity,
he's gonna choke on it.
If he swallows it, it's gonna
cause GI disturbance in him
he's gonna have diarrhea later on.
John Wick is suffering.
This is like one of the
most epic scenes in this,
but there's like 400 people
and no one can hurt John Wick.
(gunshots banging)
(bullet shells clattering)
I mean GSWs all day long,
like he's just head shots.
Like there's nothing you can do there.
It's not something you're getting up from.
And he does parkour in
his spare time, clearly.
(dramatic music)
(glass shattering)
Going through a true glass window
is actually really problematic,
'cause this glass isn't the type of glass
that's in your windshield,
that shatters into tiny little pieces.
The reason that it happens here
is because the movie makes it like that.
In real life, the glass
can actually shatter
with big, big slices of
glass that are sharp,
sticking out that can
sever a carotid artery.
So it's never as clean as
oh, you just jump through the window,
and the whole thing just explodes.
(men grunting)
The close quarters
combat here is on point.
(dramatic music)
(man screaming)
Yeah, getting stabbed
in the heart is a death.
Death, death, death injury.
(doorbell chiming)
Pizzas here!
- Pizza time.
(water sloshing)
- Okay.
Getting stabbed in the carotid
will make you bleed out very quickly.
Oh, punch in the face.
(John Wick speaking foreign language)
(man groaning)
Oh, he looked like right
there that he tore his MCL.
Cause he kicked the outside of his leg.
A medial collateral ligament
just went pop and just popped.
(John Wick speaking foreign language)
- (repeats Russian) Okay, good Russian.
See that whole cracking thing.
I don't buy that.
I don't, I know he's a killer,
but he just kinda went
like this and that's not,
that's not deathly enough.
(knife slicing)
- Getting stabbed like that in the mouth
has gotta be the most painful thing ever.
You have so many nerve
fibers in your mouth,
in your tongue, this is
why kissing feels good.
This is why you could
always feel a little blister
in your mouth or on your tongue.
That would be just, I
would scream out, oh.
(man speaking foreign language)
- (repeats Russian) Okay, good Russian.
I feel like this is also becoming
a Russian review of John Wick.
The big dude's incoming.
Waaa.
(gunshots banging)
I love that that big dude
got stabbed in the shoulder
and he eats it and then
he steps on his toe
and the guy's like, "oh, okay.
"I give up."
(intense techno music)
(film leader beeping)
(intense techno music continues)
(gunshots banging)
This area here has a lot of cartilage.
And if you break that cartilage,
it becomes hard to swallow, breathe.
Aw, that's very, very painful.
(glass shattering)
(intense techno music)
I was gonna say the glass in his eye
could become a problem
'cause it could have given
him a corneal abrasion,
but then he got shot in the head,
so that negates that problem.
(men grunting)
This is I think his worst injury, aw, aw!
Getting thrown off the balcony like that,
landing on the back.
There's a vertebral fracture.
There might even be a hip fracture
depending on how he landed on his pelvis.
But again, he's bulletproof.
- Is the Doctor in?
- [Doorman] Yes sir, 24/7.
- Send him up please.
- I'll be right there!
- [Doorman] May I suggest a drink, sir?
- I would not.
Alcohol makes your clotting worse.
My man is gonna bleed out,
keep the alcohol away
and keep the bleeding at bay.
- Take two of these
beforehand and you'll bleed,
but you'll have full function.
- I'm assuming he's giving
him some kind of amphetamine
or something to keep his pulse up.
Because if you start bleeding out
and your blood pressure drops,
you're gonna faint.
- [The Doctor] Will you
need anything for the pain?
- No, I've got that covered.
- No, just take a real pain medication.
(gunshots banging)
My man was just trying to
get some sleep to recover,
to allow his wounds to stop bleeding.
I don't know why he has a sling on
if he has a fracture, he needs a cast.
That sling is not helping.
Clearly whatever was bothering him
that he needed a sling for was not true,
considering my guy doesn't,
just takes it right off
and starts fighting.
That was the least
believable fight sequence.
She just like flew off his back
and he just went.
And she just flew off
into the air, come on now.
(gunshots banging)
Shot into the quad, ow.
She just dislocated her
thumb. Ah, that's gotta hurt.
Is she gonna put her thumb back?
- Now yeah. I'm thinking I'm back.
- I'm thinking I'm back.
If I ever go on vacation
from the hospital,
I'm just gonna walk in.
I think I'm back.
(chair clattering)
Yeah, so suffocation's a big problem.
He kicks him not to the
point where he falls,
but he kicks him to the point
where his legs go above his head.
Just like it's so not realistic.
Again they make a cracking noise,
like he's cracking everyone's necks.
No!
Abdominal GSWs are really a big problem.
You can have bleeding into
the retroperitoneal space
where you don't even realize
a person's losing a lot of blood.
That's not only a painful injury,
it's also a life-threatening one.
(man speaking foreign language)
He didn't say that. He
said like go eff yourself.
(man speaking foreign language)
(man screaming)
Oh, right in the quad!
The only thing is he went
straight down the middle.
There's a femur in there.
That bone is stronger than concrete.
So you ain't stabbing
through no femur, my friend.
(glass shattering)
(tense music)
I mean blunt force trauma like that,
you don't necessarily die from.
You get knocked out, you can
get some internal bleeding,
but you don't insta-die.
(suspenseful music)
It looks like what I open
my Mail Time videos with.
(ominous music)
(men grunting)
(thunder crashing)
That was so unnecessary.
My guy stabs himself just
to dislocate his elbow.
And it's not that easy
to dislocate an elbow,
especially when you've just been stabbed.
One got stabbed in the abdomen,
one got stabbed in the jugular.
No one's winning here.
Everyone's just wet and dying.
You might want to put some pressure
on that wound there, buddy.
This a animal hospital?
I feel like, mafia movies,
it's always an animal hospital.
You don't need peroxide,
just soapy water.
This is so unnecessary.
And he got a staple gun, okay.
I'm okay with that.
It auto folds in, it
like clasps the tissue.
It's not ideal.
You'd wanna put sutures in,
they're a little bit more flexible.
(tense music)
If someone ever did something to Bear.
I have a special set of skills.
Those skills
require tools.
I have access to those tools.
Number one tool I like to use,
scalpel.
I know where to cut with that scalpel
to make sure that
whoever did whatever they did to Bear
will no longer be doing
that to Bears again.
I'll leave it at that.
If you're over 18,
click here for Final
Destination injury reviews.
Click it, check it out.
It's gory.
It's crazy.
It doesn't make sense.
Click it.
Stay happy and healthy, but click it.
(upbeat music)